un club de nueve miembros quiere elegir
a una mesa directiva de tres personas
presidente vicepresidente y secretario
sin la elección se hace de manera
aleatoria cuál es la probabilidad de que
el resultado sea maruca para presidente
xavi está para vicepresidente y roberto
para secretario así que lo que quiero
hacer es encontrar la probabilidad de
que la presidente
maruca
la vicepresidente vicepresidente
hábitat
hábitat y el secretario
secretario
a roberto
ahora esto es simplemente una de las
posibles combinaciones que hay es una y
sólo una por lo tanto la probabilidad es
igual a 1 entre el número total de mesas
directivas número
total
de mesas directivas o es más vamos a
decir el número total de posibilidades
posibilidades
bien y cuáles es el número total de
posibilidades pues pensemos vamos a
pensar en que aquí tengo el puesto de
presidente aquí tengo el puesto de
vicepresidente y por aquí tengo el
puesto de secretario ahora vamos a
empezar eligiendo un presidente no
teníamos que hacerlo en ese orden pero
vamos a hacerlo así y para el presidente
como tengo nueve miembros los cuales
elegir tengo nueve posibilidades cuando
elijo al vicepresidente si ya elegí al
presidente solo puedo elegir entre ocho
miembros restantes del club y de para el
secretario ya ocupe la posición de
presidente y del vicepresidente así que
sólo me quedan siete lugares o siete
personas de entre las cuales elegir por
lo tanto la cantidad de comités que
podría formar es 9 por 8 por 7 que 9 por
8 al 72 así que esto sería 72 por 7 7
por 12 es 14
4 llevo 17 por ciento es 49 y 1 que
llevamos es 504 500 4 posibilidades
posibilidades de comités 504 comités o
mesas directivas distintas por lo tanto
la probabilidad que buscamos es igual a
1 entre 504